this was probably the most valuable  thing I ever learned in my life when I  was a kid my dad he was my coach  essentially he's my dad you know you're  racing and you can turn around and look  in the go-kart I used to get so pissed  at me and he would say you look where  your eyes go look forward don't turn  around but isn't that a metaphor for  everything you look where your eyes go  just like where your mind goes wherever  you set your your point of reference on  your your mental attention your focus  that is where you're going how are you  going to have a positive life from  negative thoughts you can't so if you  want to expand and grow and rise and  meet new people and do better the bigger  better things then you've got to think  about what you do want not what you  don't want so a hundred percent if  you're looking at the wall you're going  there